you
[Music]
hi everyone excited to be here to talk
to all of you about the role of data in
political campaigns as Pete mentioned
this is probably going to be pretty
different from a lot of the other
conversations happening over the next
two days but fundamentally the work that
I do and my team at the DNC does is
centered around delivering data as a
product to Democratic campaigns around
the country and so I'm really excited to
talk to this group about the role that
data plays in political campaign
strategy and how that role has changed
over time
I want to ground this conversation in a
little bit of background about what
political campaigns are fundamentally
trying to do because that drives the
discussion we have around the data that
campaigns need and how they utilize it
to effectively reach voters
[Music]
fundamentally the goals of campaigns
pretty straightforward you're trying to
win the most votes and you're trying to
do that in a resource-limited world so
campaigns are attempting to use limited
resources to efficiently net enough
votes for their candidate to win that
requires doing a few specific things
investing money in the right places in
the context of trying to flip the House
of Representatives or win the presidency
identifying the districts that are most
competitive the states that will get you
over the 270 electoral vote margin to
win the White House is the critical
first point of decision-making made by
campaigns and other political
organizations once you figured out where
to spend money making sure that you're
running cost-effective programs that net
votes efficiently is the next big piece
of campaigns jobs making sure that the
places you're spending money are
actually reaching voters and getting
them to take the actions you want and a
fundamental part of running cost
effective programs is making sure you're
focusing those programs on the right
people on the people that will actually
be moved by hearing communication from a
political campaign through a specific
program so what does this concretely
mean who are the people the campaign's
need to move and what are the programs
we run to do that most simplistically
campaigns are attempting to change the
behaviors of voters
along a few spectrums if you assume that
people start out with some initial
likelihood to support a candidate a
Democrat or Republican and some initial
likelihood to vote or to not vote the
fundamental thing campaigns are trying
to do is either increase somebody's
likelihood to support your candidate
rather than your opponent or increase
their likelihood to vote when they
otherwise wouldn't have or add new
people to the electorate through voter
registration programs specifically
focused on people that you will be able
to turnout and who will ultimately vote
for your candidate so campaign strategy
is fundamentally focused on moving
people along those spectrums and moving
enough voters in enough ways that you
will effectively net enough votes to win
that means starting by asking questions
like who are the people we need to reach
this looks different district to
district whether the thing that will win
you a campaign is persuading voters
turning out supporters who don't always
vote or expanding the electorate looks
different depending on the state of the
race and the place where you're running
a campaign once defining who that people
are you need to reach campaigns need to
understand what are the actions we need
those people to take what does it look
like to persuade them to support our
candidate to turn out to vote when they
otherwise wouldn't have or to give money
to a campaign to volunteer their time to
expand the capacity of the campaign to
reach more people towards those goals
once you know the people you're trying
to reach and the things you need those
people to do you can start asking
practical questions about the medium the
message and the messenger that will be
most effective at getting those people
to take the action you need them to take
all of these things raise a couple of
tactical questions against which you can
evaluate any program that a campaign
seeks to run we can ask are the people
that we're trying to reach in fact
reachable through a given tactic
campaigns call people they knock on
doors they send text messages they try
to reach people online the first
question is are the people were trying
to reach actually available through that
mechanism and do we have the data
available to call
somebody or to knock on their door
beyond just understanding the
availability of data on a specific
person understanding their receptiveness
to a specific mechanism of contact is
critical to spending money efficiently
and those questions in combination
knowing where do we actually have the
data to reach a person through a
specific program and what are they going
to be responsive to compared with how
much time is that going to cost how much
money is it going to cost provides the
fundamental framework for letting
campaigns evaluate the programs they run
these are all broad strategic questions
but they're also all fundamentally
questions about data they're questions
about the people who actually exist on
different places of that spectrum how do
we know people who are likely to support
a candidate or likely to be persuadable
or to be mobilized to turnout how do we
know if we're actually reaching those
people and if they're actually changing
their behavior is in response to
communication from a campaign but the
ways that campaigns have leveraged data
in order to accomplish these goals has
changed dramatically over the last 20
years so I want to talk a little bit
about the history of political data
specifically in the Democratic Party as
a grounding to talk about where we are
today and how we use data to answer
these questions so we're going to go
back to the early 2000s at this point in
time political campaigns attempted to do
all the things I just named by
identifying groups of voters using
either geographic information or
demographic information broadly to
understand who are the types of people
that would be supportive of a given
candidate who are more or less likely to
vote or who are more or less less likely
to care about certain issues the kind of
data that was available to campaigns
included things like historical election
results you wouldn't know down to a
political precinct which is the smallest
level of geography on which political
election results are officially reported
how did people vote in past elections
and what issues did they care about in
the context of political polling that
would ask people broadly who are you in
to support what issues matter to you and
would classify the population into broad
categories
of groups of people who cared about
certain things or would act in certain
ways campaigns leverage this data in a
whole bunch of different ways but
without any sort of connected system
there was no shared record-keeping of
these election results or this
aggregated data no shared record-keeping
of how voters were actually responding
when campaigns talked to them and when
campaigns went and had conversations
with voters the data they collected
lived in totally disparate systems if it
existed at all after the 2004 election
when Democrats lost the 2004
presidential election there was a
recognition that we were falling behind
in terms of collecting and utilizing
data about the electorate so in the
years after the 2004 election the
Democratic Party embarked on a program
to actually construct a national voter
file that meant standardizing data about
individual voters across all 50 states
and providing that data to campaigns
state parties and other political
entities in a centralized CRM so that
all voter contact activity could be
trapped in the standardized way just to
talk a little bit about what the voter
file actually is because this is
fundamentally the backbone of what
political data is and what the data
product is that the Democratic National
Committee provides to Democratic
campaigns when you register to vote you
provide certain information to your
state that data is generally publicly
available and their rural state to state
around what data can be provided to whom
but generally states collect information
like your name your address which
includes information about what
elections you're eligible to vote in and
your vote history in some states they
also collect information like the
political party you registered for your
date of birth your gender your race and
contact information like phone numbers
these data files look different state to
state both in terms of their content and
their structure especially at this time
requesting this kind of data from a
state would sometimes come digitally
sometimes come in the mail
and there was no standard structure to
either what you would get from any state
or how it was organized so the
fundamental task of the of the party
during this time was compile this voter
data from around the country standardize
it and provided in a CRM so that
everybody had access any campaign
running for office Democrat running for
office had access to the same
information regardless of where they
were
that meant that going into the 2008
Obama campaign the presidential campaign
and campaigns up and down the ballot had
a complete list of registered voters
available to them again with varying
levels of actual data available to state
to state but in a standardized format
that also meant that people were now
starting to participate and feed
additional data into the shared central
CRM this shows just the growth of
adoption of the CRM that's used to track
organizing activities there was
scattered use in the early 2000s of the
central tool that is now used by
Democratic champions around the country
to enter data into a shared system by
2008 50 states were all contributing
data from the doors they were knocking
the phone calls they were making and the
other interactions they were having with
voters around the country that laid the
groundwork for the significant
advancements in political analytics that
came in the following years some of this
was tested in 2008 and 2010 but by the
2012 obama reelection campaign there was
a team on the ground that was able to
harness the data that had been compiled
since the advent of the National Voter
file around 2005 and the data that had
been collected through the 2008 and 2010
election cycles in addition to the data
from the states and collected in the
field the Obama campaign collected an
appended significant new data on top of
the voter file that included consumer
data about people's purchasing habits
socio-economic traits and other
variables in addition to ongoing surveys
run by the campaign to provide real-time
information about how people felt about
the candidates in the 2012 race the
issues they cared about and more this
provided the framework for leveraging
advanced analytics to predict voter
behavior on an individual level this
shows just the rise of the total amount
of data being collected just through
organizing programs through 2008 and
2012 that provided the data foundation
for making some of these campaign
decisions the 2012 Obama analytics
program was the foundation of how
political analytics are leveraged in
campaigns today so I wanted to spend a
minute talking concretely about what
that looked like folks had probably
interacted with predictive models in
some contexts but I want to talk a
little bit about what me how addictive
analytics particularly works in
campaigns the Obama campaign for
instance ran significant surveys to
collect data about voter opinions and
preferences primarily collected by
making phone calls to a sample of voters
taken from the voter file designed to
look like a representative sample of the
people who are going to vote in the 2012
election ask them direct questions about
who they were going to vote for coat
those responses and then build models
off of that and all of the other traits
that we had about voters in order to
provide predictive probabilities about
the likely behavior of campaign of each
voter in the upcoming election what that
means concretely is that the campaign
was able to take every individual on the
voter file going back to this basic grid
of what campaigns are trying to do
identify voters on a scale of supportive
to non supportive and of likely voters
to unlikely voters and assign a zero to
one score to every voter on those two
traits so that coupled with experimental
analysis that campaign started running
around this time allowed us to identify
the pockets of voters they were actually
most efficient to talk to we know for
instance that the most efficient place
to net votes for a candidate is by
talking to people who are very likely to
support your candidate have to support
scores very close to one and who have
turnout scores in the middle of the
range meaning they're people who vote
sometimes but not all
whose behavior is inconsistent and who
are most likely to be affected by a
nudge from a campaign to turn out and
vote it's important to note here the
political the models built in the
political context are designed both to
predict the behavior of individual
people but also to give us an aggregate
idea of how the entire electorate is
going to perform understanding with some
degree of uncertainty baked in what is
likely to happen on aggregate
how is across an entire state are going
to behave is also an essential part of
the question of spending resources in
the right place by understanding the
states that are likely to come down to
the thinnest margin and where a put up
the investment of a political program
could make the biggest difference so
this work all happened around the 2012
election it also necessitated
significant investment not just in new
data collection but also in technology
that would make the aggregation and
utilization of this data possible so
leading into the 2012 election the Obama
campaign in partnership with the DNC
worked to overhaul the technology
platform that campaigns were using as a
foundation for analytics specifically
that meant adopting Vertica a tool
bought by HP around this time as a data
warehouse and analytics platform to
store the voter file and to take in all
of the data that was coming from fueled
campaigns from emails being sent to
supporters and from other data sources
being generated by the Obama campaign in
2012 in many ways Vertigo was the tool
that made it possible for campaigns to
run advanced analytics and for the 2012
campaign especially to harness all of
the data that was become being available
from both public records consumer
sources and campaigns in the field in
order to run effective targeted programs
as I mentioned this work has been the
foundation of analytics and campaigns in
the six or so years since then but over
that time there have also been
significant changes in how campaigns
operate and in the scale of data being
collected by them specifically cycle
over cycle we've seen
a significant rise in the collection of
data and in the utilization of advanced
analytics not just by presidential
campaigns but by campaigns up and down
the ballot to run more efficiently
targeted programs that means that well
both 20 2008 and 2012 were high-water
marks at the time for the amount of
voter data being collected those lines
were exceeded in 2016 and again during
the 2018 election just in terms of the
volume of data being collected what this
meant
especially in 2018 was that we had a
platform around the country that
provided candidates up and down the
ballot with advanced analytics tools
that allowed us to focus resources in
the right places and in many ways this
is part of what drove historic wins
around the country in the last year so
in 2018 we saw historic levels of
volunteerism for president for
Democratic campaigns around the country
with more than one and a half million
people signing up to volunteer for
campaigns and completing and signing up
for more than four million volunteer
activities that meant also generating an
unprecedented level of information from
direct contacts with with voters
specifically campaigns this year
attempted more people and knocked on
more doors than any presidential cycle
or any other cycle on record in this
shared database and reached out to more
voters than the last two midterm
elections 2010 and 2014 combined
specifically campaigns were able to
leverage data and analytics to run
targeted programs that focused on the
districts in the country that were most
competitive including 42 congressional
districts around the country the
Democrats flipped by investing
significantly more resources in than in
the pinyon past midterm elections
specifically within only these targeted
districts we saw more than 40 million
points of outreach to voters living in
these 42 competitive congressional
districts and talked to millions more
voters in those districts than in the
same districts in 2014
that means we're generating
significantly more data but it's also
important to know that the nature of the
day
being generated is changing as campaign
programs change themselves one of the
biggest examples of this and that is
most apparent in the data we have is the
rise of text messaging as a political
outreach mechanism this peer-to-peer
one-to-one text messaging it was
non-existent as a technology in 2014
made up 0 percent of all of the outreach
from campaigns to voters a few companies
came onto the market in 2015 that
facilitated large scale but one-to-one
conversations between volunteers and
voters through text messaging and during
the 2016 election around 6% of all
outreach that happened to voters
happened via SMS in the 2018 campaign
that number was 30 percent so
significant change in the nature of the
data being collected from this kind of
engagement text messaging is also very
clearly reflected here there are other
trends and changes that are generating
new data but don't yet fully appear in
these numbers there are more campaigns
reaching out and engaging with voters
more significantly online than in the
past and we'll talk a bit more in a
minute about some of the other big
trends that are changing the nature of
the data being generated by campaigns
but one of the results of this was that
significantly more data has come in
between 2012 through 2016 and into 2018
the data has come in a lot of different
shapes and forms and the technological
infrastructure that was built and to
allow a lot of this analytics to happen
that facilitated a lot of the predictive
analytics revolution in campaigns in
2012 by 2018 was fundamentally
hamstringing the work of the party to
actually conduct meaningful analytics
work specifically Vertica maintain
continued to be the tool that we use to
store and display a voter file data in a
data warehouse it was absorbing
significantly more data from more
external sources and political analytics
has boomed as an industry over this
period of time meaning we've had a
significant rise in the number of people
using and engaging with Vertica and with
democratic data directly in this system
so one of the things that that meant was
that by 2016
Vertica which had been really
Ellucian area in 2012 was the system
that was largely ban dated together and
being held up and just kept barely alive
by a group of very dedicated engineers
and we were in a world where a new
analyst learning sequel for the first
time interacting with Vertica and
writing a single bad query could topple
the entire system over for every user on
the campaign the only like tiny silver
lining of this was that we were during
the Clinton campaign in 2016 as analysts
working approximately 20 hour days for
seven days a week for months on end so
occasionally Vertica toppling for
several hours was the only kind of break
that we actually got during the day not
a great silver lining but something so
fundamentally the tech infrastructure
has not held up to the kinds of data
being generated and the kind of work
being done within the industry that
means that right now as we assess the
current role of data and politics we
need to think not only about the data
were gathering and how we're harnessing
it to run more effective efficient
programs but we also need to think about
how we're building technological
infrastructure that makes it possible to
collect and deploy that data at scale
this is about not only making sure that
as campaign programs change we're
capturing the data so that we know
what's happening but it's also about
connecting identifying opportunities for
integration within that data so data can
proactively lead changes in campaign
strategy identify new areas for
integration and identify new ways to
reach and engage with voters so I want
to talk about what that looks like
and questions who are evaluating in the
role of data and campaigns today in
three broad categories first when we
think about targeting voters and running
efficient programs we need to make sure
we're collecting the data we need to
identify who those target voters are who
the people are who are most likely to be
moved by engagement with political
campaigns and we are collecting the data
we need to be able to reach them
somewhere through an effective mechanism
that will engage them and take move them
to take action second we need to make
sure we're not just identifying some
people
who will respond to campaign messaging
but are effectively collecting the data
that we need to efficient effectively
model the behavior of the entire
electorate and understand likely
outcomes that's critical for making sure
in the context of for instance the
upcoming presidential campaign were able
to identify where we need to invest
resources and where they will have the
highest effect at tipping the outcome of
the electoral college and then finally
we need to make sure we're creating
infrastructure that supports these
changes collects the data that's
available to us now and is not just
designed to handle today's data but it's
able to evolve as the data available to
campaigns is continually shifting so
concretely what does this mean when we
look at being able to identify target
voters and reach them effectively we
just talked about how the activity of
political campaigns has expanded
significantly in 2016 and 2018 we're
producing a significant significantly
higher volume of outreach to voters than
we were before but we're also running
into some roadblocks specifically the
ways that voters are engaging with
political campaigns is changing in ways
that are making traditional forms of
outreach less effective specifically if
you look at how likely a voter is to
answer the phone when a political
campaign calls them that number has been
cut in half between 2010 and 2013 and
sir when they're called they're also
less likely to answer a knock on their
door or in other ways engage with
traditional campaign outreach this is a
problem because it makes voters on the
whole harder to reach but also because
these effects are not distributed
uniformly across all of the people that
campaigns are trying to target
specifically well the contact rates are
falling across the board specific target
audiences are especially being left
behind in 2018 for instance a voter
under 40 with half as likely to answer a
phone call as a voter over 70 what that
means is that well approximately 29% of
all of the people that campaigns tried
to call during 2018 were under 40
only around 19% of the people that we
actually reached or and conversely well
approximately 19% of the people we tried
to reach were over the age of 70
those people represented closer to 30%
of all campaign contacts so that means
that we know that there are particular
groups of people especially groups like
younger voters that we know are
especially important targets for
campaigns to reach and mobilize to vote
that are uniquely hard to reach through
traditional outreach the silver lining
here is that there are a whole host of
new technologies coming into the space
that are designed to provide a plethora
of new ways to engage with voters
significant rise in new tactics that
open up new opportunities first to talk
to people text messages is one great
example of this that's risen to really
huge proportion in the last few election
cycles but over the last few years
campaigns have also tested technology
that interacts with voters through
chatbots embedded in social media pages
other direct forms of direct social
media engagement and some low-tech tools
we've seen a rise in people in campaigns
using post card programs to write to
voters direct handwritten messages
between volunteers and voters talking to
them about their concerns we've also
seen a particular rise in technology
that's designed to tap into the
individual relationships between
campaign volunteers and activists and
people that they already know and have
relationships with who can be moved and
mobilized by hearing from a trusted
messenger but we know that fully
measuring the effect of relational
organizing requires a new form of data
capture understanding how social
networks actually map to moving people
to vote and what messengers are most
effective over time at mobilizing people
they know to turn out a number of these
new tools and tactics have been
fundamentally grounded in engaging with
voters online and in many ways this is
changing not just the face of campaign
organizing but also of the data that
is being collected well campaigns had
classically engaged with voters in a way
that was fundamentally built around the
voter file around defining a list of
voters to start with calling those
people directly tracking those
one-on-one engagements there are new
challenges specifically when we know
that that social media is the first
place that many voters are ever going to
interact with a campaign that will have
interaction points there that aren't
directly mapped back to individual
behaviors on individual behaviors we can
track on a voter file and it raises both
new opportunities but also new
challenges in our ability to track the
effectiveness of programs when we've
traditionally been able to measure
whether a program works based on an
individual record of the voter file
which ultimately comes back with a
record of whether or not that person
turned out in the election that we were
running program around when we start to
think about measuring online engagement
in a really serious way we need to start
moving beyond that voter file contained
view of people to understand more
holistically how people are interacting
in the world whether or not we're able
to map them directly back to a human on
the voter file and that foundation of
democratic data this starts with
understanding how are we as campaigns
engaging with voters online how are
people engaging with our web sites and
social media activities what things are
they responding positively or negatively
to but fundamentally a truly 360 degree
view of voters requires not just
understanding our own interactions with
campaigns on with voters online but also
understanding how voters are being
affected by discussion by other targeted
messaging that happens on the Internet
one starting point of that is that we're
working within the Democratic Party to
build a data exchange that will allow us
to track in real time information about
not just how our campaigns are talking
to voters but how organizations across
the progressive world are talking to
voters online and offline this is
actually an idea borrowed from the
Republican Party which exchanges data
through a
to track information about how every
different organization within the
Republican ecosystem is having
conversations with the same voters
mirroring this idea and the Democratic
side gives us an opportunity to both
understand a more holistic picture of
how voters are engaging with campaigns
but also to solve for inefficiencies
where campaigns are inundating the same
voters with the same message or are
learning the same lessons in separate
ways about what voters are and aren't
responding effectively to but we also
know that we're at a moment where trust
in political organizations as messengers
is at an all-time low so the answer
can't just be understanding how people
are hearing information from us as
political organizations
it also means things like understanding
what the organic conversation is that
voters are having online how they're
talking about political issues in public
online forums like Twitter how they're
behaving the issues that are moving them
and that are moving them either
positively or negatively to care about a
political candidate beyond that part of
this is also understanding and taking
seriously the political reality that
political organizations working for
candidates are not the only
organizations that are targeting voters
online with political messaging but we
also have to be aware of the role that
malicious actors play in seeking to
actively confuse or fuel distrust among
voters we know that in 2016 this kind of
activity on social media was played a
serious role in showing distrust in the
2016 election and we know that still
today there are ongoing dedicated
efforts by foreign adversaries to dis
inform voters for the purpose not just
an undermining space in our candidates
but in the political process as a whole
understanding this and being able to
engage with it effectively it
fundamentally requires taking this
360-degree approach to understanding all
of the ways that voters are learning
information about political candidates
online and about
pardis how they're talking to others how
they're being talked to by other
organizations so that we can identify
they both what is effectively moving
voters from our side but also where
their specific threats of disinformation
that voters are being influenced by that
we need to be able to target and combat
so all of these factors are relevant to
understanding who we need to be
targeting what kind of program we should
be targeting at them in order to reach
and effectively move those people to
take action and where we need to engage
to combat things that are happening
online that are influencing voters
negatively but all of these changes in
how voters engage with campaigns also
has implications for our ability to
understand the behaviors of the
electorate as a whole specifically we
talked earlier about the importance of
being able to model the behavior of the
entire electorate in order to understand
what states are going to have close
elections where we can effectively
allocate resources but as contact rates
decline as people pick up the doors and
phones less often our ability to do
those things in particular is being
challenged political polling has
historically relied on primarily phone
calls to voters and until relatively
recently has relied on phone calls to
voters with landlines to have
conversations about their political
beliefs as phone contact rates have
declined and as we talked about have
declined unevenly across different
groups in the population we know that
the people who are answering their phone
and engaging in 15-minute conversations
with pollsters are probably not
representative of the electorate overall
we know especially that it is uniquely
hard to get responses from certain
segments of the population which means
it's easy to underrepresented groups in
political polling or to have to up wait
the responses of a small number of
respondents and make a small sample
speak for the beliefs or behaviors been
entire population in ways that can be
dangerous and misleading in the last few
years there's been a concerted effort to
combat this problem with a rise in
Newport News
is to pull and understand the opinions
of voters including through polling on
things like online forums these do
though carry their own risk part of the
reason that polling has traditionally
happened through phone calls is because
it gave us a very easy framework for
saying we will take a list of people
from the voter file we will build a
sample that reflects what the electorate
is going to look like and we can confirm
when we're talking to somebody that it's
actually the voter we believed it to be
using a combination of phone number and
demographic data when polling expands
online we risk losing that opportunity
and facing challenges with our ability
to match the responses being collected
online to an individual voter record
which means there are new risks that
were building samples of voters that are
not in fact representative of the
population overall finally we know that
there beyond just polling online there
are significant rise in just the data
available as people are talking in
online public forums about their
political beliefs and opinions and we
should be able to capture and harness
this data to understand people's
preferences for political candidates or
their concerns about specific political
issues but we also know that among all
of the information being generated
through conversation online it's going
to be a challenge to effectively
separate the signal from the noise in a
way that can give us meaningful
predictive information about elections
one specific example of this comes from
an article it was in the New York Times
in the upshot earlier this week that
looked at the differences between people
between Democrats especially who post on
social media and those that don't their
research found that people Democrats who
post political content online are more
likely than the Democratic electorate
overall to be highly educated to have
college degrees to be white and to
donate to political organizations among
a host of other differences what that
means is that we have to be very
attentive and aware of the fact that we
can't just model or take for granted the
information being generated online is
meaningfully reflective of the things
that people care about or the issues
that matter to voters
so across all of these problems we have
both new sources of data that give us
new opportunities to learn more about
who we should talk to about what's going
to happen in elections in about the
effective ways to run program that
reaches voters around the country but we
also know that we need to build a system
that effectively utilizes this data that
understands what's working and what's
not and that is a fact that is able to
track new sources of data as they come
in so again that starts with expanding
our core set of data about voters beyond
just the voter file to a 360 degree view
of how voters are engaging with
campaigns with each other and with other
organizations
it means routinely incorporating new
data sources these are just a handful of
companies that have come into existence
just over the last four years that are
generating data in new structures and
forms some on an individual level that
we can match back to records on the
voter file some in aggregate and in
other forms but they give us new
opportunities to learn what's working in
what's not in political data but require
building a flexible adaptable data model
that both incorporates these sources of
information and the new ones that we
know are likely to arise over the next
two years and beyond
finally it requires moving away from
technology that's going to fall over
whenever a new person starts learning
how to interact with data in it so
that's meant in 2018 or 2019 as we
prepare for 2020 we are retiring Vertica
as the backbone of this entire
infrastructure we're moving to a data
warehouse built on Google bigquery so
that fundamentally people can interact
with all of this data without risking
knocking the entire system over to
provide both a secure and stable
foundation for analysts and data
scientists and to provide a foundation
that people can build on top of and can
do new innovative work that pushes the
bounds of political data forward and
drives the political strategy as a
result so we're facing a lot of both
challenges and opportunities as the data
available to campaigns shifts and
provides new opportunities for how we
use that data to engage
voters I know there are things that are
unique to that data in the political
world but there are also a lot of these
challenges that aren't unique the
challenges of data integration
standardization in effective utilization
is something that exists across
industries and so I'm really excited to
be here with all of you talking about
and learning from the challenges that
we've all worked with to make politics
even better and how we utilize data to
advance our strategic goals thank you
[Applause]
voter behavior to vote for candidate
what about the flip side of that to
influence and impact voter behavior to
build resentment against a character or
against voting at all yeah well so I
know I'm actually I'll flip back a
couple of sides we know that there are
organizations that are explicitly trying
to do this these are all actual examples
of social media posts explicitly
designed to provide false information to
voters give people suggested voters for
instance that they can vote online by
tweeting their votes and they don't need
to bother showing up just so distrust
among for instance we know that this was
the thing that was used to sow distrust
among Democrats after the primary ended
in 2016 and so divisive nests between
people who had supported two different
candidates during the primary it's
absolutely a risk we absolutely think
it's affecting voter behavior our goal
is the Democratic Party is to make
voting accessible to engage people and
turn them out to vote so explicitly
discouraging behavior or sowing that
distrust is the thing that we're
fundamentally trying to combat but we
know we know that it's a risk and we
know that being able to collect the data
on when that's happening who's being
targeted by it and who it is effectively
influencing is critical to our ability
to actually combat that sort of
challenge you said that you have
campaigns to influence voters do you
have any such campaigns to attract more
volunteers do you do any kind of
exercise to encourage more people to
sign up as volunteers yeah absolutely
so I talked so question was what we do
to attract more people to volunteer so I
talked a little bit about the data
that campaign field programs are
collecting from doors that are knocked
in phone calls that are made that the
same CRM that we use to track engagement
with voters is also used to track
engagement between activists and
volunteers with campaigns which means
we've also developed a robust more than
a decade-long system of record-keeping
of everybody who shows up and volunteers
comes to an event in support of a
campaign so on we just talked about a
couple of the predictive models that
campaigns build in order to target
voters identifying support and turnout
we also do things like specifically
modeling for propensity to volunteer to
understand the traits that make somebody
likely to be an activist with with a
campaign we make that available to
organizations all over the country it is
it's been especially interesting over
the last two years as there's been a
massive spike in engagement with
Democratic campaigns after the 2016
election a massive rise in volunteerism
and that's provided a new wealth of data
that helps us identify people who are
now engaging in the political process as
activists and volunteers but hadn't
historically but harnessing that data to
help future campaigns is definitely one
of our focuses
[Music]